es hat mich nicht beunruhigt dass olaf
scholz in den umfragen vorne liegt es
hat mich beunruhigt dass rund 33 prozent
der potenziellen spd will nichts mehr
wollen als ein gesundheitsminister nahm
karl lauterbach ich möchte nicht dass
die spd ausschließt dass sie mit der
linken koaliert ich möchte dass die spd
ausschließt dass karl lauterbach
gesundheitsminister wird nach anderthalb
jahren von panik propaganda
angstmacherei wahlkampf den er gegen
kinder gemacht hat schreckensszenarien
dir für eltern ausgemalt hat toten
großeltern die er an die wand gemalt hat
wenn die kinder vielleicht mal zu laut
wiesen würden glaube ich karl lauterbach
ist für vieles qualifiziert mit
sicherheit für talkshows vielleicht
haben wir nochmal bald wieder hier zu
gast bei uns war auch schon mal aber
ganz sicher nicht für ein ministeramt
karl lauterbach hat sich zu einem
erklärer gemacht und dabei vor allem
eines erklärt warum er der größte
experte ist und dabei so oft falsch
gelegen wie kaum jemand anderes in
dieser corona krise deswegen lieber spd
ob wir mit der linkspartei zusammen geht
oder nicht das müsst ihr für mich nicht
ausschließen aber bitte bitte bitte
macht deutlich dass karl lauterbach
solltet ihr die wahl gewinnen nicht
unser nächster gesundheitsminister wird
ich kann zwar verstehen dass du karl
lauterbach nicht für den besten experten
dieser republik hält aber aus meiner
sicht gibt es auch in der spd noch
andere kandidaten für ministerämter die
absolut nicht ministrabel sind wenn ich
da an kevin kühnert denke wenn ich da an
das kersken denke oder an norbert walter
borjans davon würde ich mir ehrlich
gesagt noch mehr sorgen machen wovor
hast du angst bei kevin kühnert kevin
kühnert und bild haben ja auch eine
lange wunderbare geschichte ist
schrecklich an kevin kühnert abdi
enteignungs fantasien die ja auch schon
mal geäußert hat gerade auch was große
automobilkonzerne animiert da denke ich
sofort das ist echt eigentlich nicht
mehr die spd wie ich sie kenne das ist
schon fast die linkspartei und genau
deswegen müssen wir auch rot-rot-grün in
diesem land verhindern bmw wollte er
aneignen eher von kühler tja bmw wollte
ereignet ich glaube da ist er wieder
runter seit der stellvertreter
parteivorsitzender geworden ist hat er
sicherlich mehr mehr mehrfach gemäßigt
männer mehrfach gemäßigt und ist ein
bisschen sanfter er tritt ja auch kaum
noch käufer wie ein juso vorsitzender
das kind kennst du ja aus deinen eigenen
erfahrung dass man als tatsächlich
nachwuchspolitiker ein bisschen forscher
auftritt muss finde ich super es ist ja
so ich gar nicht sagen ich habe letztens
noch ein nettes gespräch mit wieder mit
kindern er mir durchgelesen und da hat
man gesagt mit den linken will ja
koalieren also er will mit denen
gespräche gehen und vor allem sollte man
diese ausschließeritis mal sein lassen
weil mit dieser ausschließeritis hätte
man so lange keine neue regierung bilden
können und das wäre so dass große in der
große coup von cdu union und da habe ich
mir ehrlich gesagt gesagt na ja gut da
der ganz klar gesagt wenn die
ausschließeritis so abwehr hatte da war
ja ganz klar wieder der user kevin und
ich nehme auch ganz gern enteignungs
kevin weil also
ich fand er war exakt nach wie vor so
wie ich ihn immer kannte ich habe mal
eine frage zur enteignungs kevin was
machen wir eigentlich wenn am wahltag
wir sind ja hier vermutlich alle keine
großen fans der linkspartei was machen
wir eigentlich sechsundzwanzigster
september 18 uhr erste hochrechnung
kommt und es ist der spd gelungen die
linkspartei unter die fünf prozent
grenze zu drängen und rauszuwerfen aus
dem parlament sind wir dann eigentlich
alle der spd dankbar
ich gehöre ja hier obwohl es nicht passt
zu den dienstältesten am tisch ich
befürchte ich bin ist sogar aber kommen
natürlich aus einer anderen aus einem
anderen politikverständnis heraus und
für mich ist politik natürlich auch in
gewisser weise mit spannung verbunden
dass irgendwas passiert ich war
wahnsinnig enttäuscht als es nicht zur
koalition kam war nach der letzten wahl
weil ich gedacht habt da ist irgendetwas
da ist eine änderung da passiert
irgendwas nicht im so müde von dem was
jetzt in der deutschen politik 16 jahre
los war dass ich ich wäre der grösste
leidtragende was vermögenssteuer
betrifft was die machen was die
geschwindigkeitsbegrenzungen betrifft
aber alles in allem wünsche ich mir
änderungen egal wie es aussieht
hauptsache es passiert was hauptsache
das gerät in diesem land mal irgend
etwas in bewegung es dreht sich
irgendwas es gärt dieses ewige gleich
gleich macht einen so müde und der trump
für ein unheil für amerika aber an
diesem abend als der geräte oder hat man
gesagt wenigstens passiert etwas und
diese destruction dass die jungen leute
ja und alle wollen das ist etwas was man
ja als heilsam ansieht endlich kommt
stimmung auf ja wir sollten nichts zu
tun wir sind übrigens sehr schnell
vielleicht gerade noch mal wieder hin
zurück von karl zu kämpfen gekommen aber
zumindest beginnen mit k es ist immer
toll beide wollen wir nicht aber zweimal
jetzt die möglichkeit gegeben schon in
der geschichte es wird ja mal so
bekannten gottes will die linkspartei
steht vor der tür 2005 hat die
möglichkeit gegeben zu gerhard schröder
natürlich mit grünen und die linkspartei
eine regierung zu bilden die mehrheit
war da 2009 war die mehrheit genau so da
beides mal wurde nicht gemacht oder
abseits sagt im grunde ich fahre mit
nicks dass vier räder hat und dann sagen
sagen sie doch dass sie nicht im auto
fahren aber auch gestern war es doch
ganz klar dass er gesagt hat es gebietet
der respekt vor den wählerinnen und
wählern so steht es auch in einem
parteitagsbeschluss der spd tatsächlich
die man kann sagen das ist eine offene
flanke deswegen wird das ja hier auch
nicht vorgetragen das ist ganz klar
hätte ich auch aber trotzdem ist es eine
offene flanke für ihn aber zweimal die
möglichkeit ergeben sich aber keiner das
möchte er kann ja ganz klar sagen wir
wollen nicht mit der linken koalieren
das tun wir als cdu ja auch aber da ist
auch noch mal dass ich sage nicht dass
ich nicht mit herrn maßen sich nicht von
ihm distanzieren das ist ja genauso
offen geblieben leider gestern nicht so
nachgefragt in diesem duell wie die
anderen dinge also das war wirklich ein
offener punkt da müssen sie schon ein
bisschen mehr über die antwort auf bevor
wir ganz kurz noch mal probe zuhören
zuhören maßen kommen noch einmal ganz
kurz zurück zur spd und so der frage
könnte ist nicht der größte verdienst
sein die der spd und auch der linken in
der spd von kevin kühnert von saskia
esken von norbert walter borjans die
linkspartei vielleicht aus dem parlament
zu schmeiß ich meine so knapp an der
fünf prozent grenze waren sie ja noch
nie müssten wir müssten wir dann nicht
alle dankbar ist indessen ganz entspannt
punkt von der julian ehrlich gesagt und
er sollte das passieren würde ich olaf
scholz blumenstrauß schicken und jeder
weiß hier in der hunde ich verspreche
dass heute abend ich schicke ob er ihn
dann bekommt es die andere frage aber
sollte urlaub stolz und ich bin kein fan
von ihm die linke rauskriegen mitunter 5
werde ich ihn blumenstrauß schicken weil
für mich sind die linken hier keine
demokratische partei das sagen
wir sind zwar los dafür haben wir jetzt
den kühnert und die deg saskia das ist
im wesentlichen ja auch eine aber selbst
kevin kühnert er kennt ja die nato an
also ich finde schon ich bin überhaupt
kein fan von enteignung scannen und
versteckt mich saskia ja aber die beiden
sind schon nicht ganz so links wie die
linken deswegen ich glaube das war schon
okay aber auch stolz dass wirklich
schaffe ich meine wenn man als hanseaten
kenne ich habe wo ich ja natürlich auch
ja und wenn ich mir angucke hat scholz
ja eigentlich auch die cdu auf jeden
fall immer mit gestriffen weil er
eigentlich so konservatives selber ist
das ist ja ich so ein bisschen des
trojaners spiel was die spd momentan
auch macht und ob scholz dann wirklich
die ganzen linken wähler abholen kann
ich wage es zu bezweifeln dass das
tatsächlich so kommen ich wollte einfach
mal was über karl lauterbach sagte
die bahn habe aber man ist ja als wähler
in irgendeiner form darauf angewiesen
sich an menschen zu reden und er
lauterbach hat es geschafft zu einer
pandemie größe zu werden
also wenn man in irgendeiner form
verlautbarungen zu krone ist immer
lauter war mit dabei und man fängt an
ihn als fachmann zur kasse vor gericht
nachweisen gelesen ja aber gelesen
betont dass der vortragende studios
arbeitet ja also ich bin ja immer da für
sich da an den fakten zwei festmachen
karl lauterbach hat ein großes problem
dass er nicht carla ist denn die spd
wird wenn sie denn in die region kommt
wie man es gibt
333 mitglieder in dieser regierung 14
minister dann gehen vielleicht vier an
die spd oder vielleicht fünf aber vier
da müssen zwei frauen darunter seien aus
nrw ist wenn ihr schulze gesetz die
justizministerin und für ihn wird
bleiben denke ich mal der posten eines
parlamentarischen staatssekretärs der
kanaren in talkshows verbreiten oder vor
den dingen warnen was er auch getan hat
die da kommen sie rettet uns die
frauenquote von carlotta außer auch das
ist möglich wie wir jüngst bei den
grünen erlebt haben er fühlt sich am tag
der kabinett berufen als frau vor
wenigen tagen so geschehen bei den
grünen ein mann der über der quotierung
regelung der grünen trotzdem in ein amt
wolter hat dein leben tag gesagt ich
fühle mich heute als und ist tatsächlich
gewählt worden also brillante analyse
von béla anda wie immer warum es
vermutlich nicht zumindest erreichen
wird aber tatsächlich ist es immer noch
möglich über diese schiene sozusagen als
weiblicher nachrücker und gefühlte carla
wir haben über dieses thema hier schon
mal gesprochen da war meine haltung man
kann mit diesem thema spielerisch
umgehen aber ich denke für viele
menschen die diesen schritt gehen ist es
ein wirklich sehr sehr starker und
harter schritt und sich dazu zu bekennen
zum anderen geschlecht dass man
vielleicht in sich fühlt wir sollen auch
den man zugestehen dass es ist aber
tatsächlich neulich so geschehen ein
grüner der das nur an dem einen tag
gesagt hat um noch in einen anzug kommt
und ich glaube auch ein bisschen ja
vielleicht ein bisschen seiner eigenen
partei den spiegel vor augen zu halten
wie was für ein grosses gespräche führen
kann sobald man den namen karl
lauterbach erwähnt vielleicht auch ein
guter trick für jedes dinner wasser ein
bisschen schläfrig geworden ist
[Musik]